foreign  we are taking a live look now at  Washington D.C as our local business  leaders meet with the Las Vegas chamber  and they're attending the annual fly-in  it's a chance to bring Nevada's  legislative priorities not only to our  delegation but also to Congressional  members from around the country one  message they want to send is don't bring  a nuclear site to Yucca Mountain  nuclear  proliferation is still on the rise and  so what are we going to do with that  nuclear waste and so the message is  you know Yucca Mountain is only 90 miles  away from Las Vegas and that is not the  place to put something like a repository  we can also tell you that the chamber  plans to talk about water conservation  and also road projects along i-11 and  I-15